even though oil prices have started to
come down a bit due to fears of a
recession they're still more than double
what they were two years ago and while
high prices are a problem for many
global economies they've actually been a
boon for opec plus countries here's how
opec plus members are benefiting from
russia's war in ukraine and how opec
plus decisions have given russia a
buffer against sanctions
first let's look at who makes up opec
plus and why high oil prices are so
important to them opec plus includes the
13 members of the saudi-led organization
of the petroleum exporting countries
otherwise known as opec plus 10 non-opec
producers led by russia together these
countries control more than half of the
world's oil output and while there are
disputes and sometimes failure to follow
through on commitments they generally
work together to exert control over the
price of crude as one analyst i talked
to put it coordination is king some oil
experts say that opec plus has a
so-called goldilocks objective they
don't want oil prices too hot since that
can tip the world into a recession but
they also don't want oil prices too cold
because many of these countries rely on
revenue from oil to balance their
budgets and pay for things like social
services and military spending even
though the key architect of the opec
plus alliance mohammed barkindo recently
passed away his efforts are likely to
continue impacting oil producers and
consumers for years to come
when the pandemic hit falling demand for
oil caused the opec plus alliance to
briefly crack and oil prices to collapse
battering many opec plus countries
so when the world opened back up and
demand for oil bounced back opec plus
countries agreed to start pumping more
oil together but at a slow and steady
pace to support prices that slow and
steady pace frustrated some global
leaders like president biden as oil
prices surged the white house is
confronting the spike in gas prices by
telling opec it must do more to support
global production then russia invaded
ukraine and oil prices soared even
higher the price of oil surged over 100
a barrel in hours after russia launched
the attack while many western nations
slapped sanctions on russia and cut ties
with the kremlin opec plus leaders
continued to honor that slow and steady
deal they struck with moscow despite
pressure from the u.s at the time saudi
and emirati leaders declined calls with
president biden as he was trying to
contain a surge in oil prices and
alienate russia since russia's oil
revenues are used to finance its war
everybody leaves his politics at the
outside door of that building
so now we have high oil prices and those
high oil prices are benefiting opec plus
countries here are five reasons why
first their economies are growing while
the war in ukraine is dealing an
economic setback for much of the world
the imf estimates that oil producers in
the middle east and north africa will
receive an additional 320 billion
dollars more than expected this year
some countries like iraq and algeria are
using the extra cash to help their
citizens boosting pensions expanding
benefits and passing laws to mitigate
rising costs other opec plus members
like saudi arabia and the uae are
spending billions of dollars abroad to
project power and enhance their security
interests in recent months riyadh and
abu dhabi have struck investment deals
and approved aid packages to the tune of
billions of dollars to help regional
neighbors like pakistan turkey and egypt
and according to analysts i spoke to
high oil prices might even help lead to
a revived nuclear deal with iran another
opec plus member since the country could
bring up to 1.5 million barrels a day of
oil to the market and finally another
opec plus member that has benefited from
high oil prices russia even though
russia isn't producing as much oil as it
normally would because of sanctions high
oil prices are helping it make more
money on the oil that it is selling
according to the center for research on
energy and clean air in the first 100
days of russia's war it raked in 97
billion dollars from fossil fuel exports
so why does all of this matter because
oil prices affect all of us but also
because russia continues to use oil
revenue to finance its war some opec
leaders are saying that even if they
wanted to pump more oil they can't
they're reaching max capacity now there
are fears of a recession and some
investors think slowing economic growth
could push demand for oil lower once
again and when demand falls prices
usually do too that's why some analysts
say that opec plus isn't likely to kick
russia out of the alliance or
dramatically ramp up pressure on moscow
because opec plus will ultimately need
russia's cooperation in order to control
oil prices in the future speaking of oil
prices they are sure to be a hot topic
when president biden visits saudi arabia
later this month check out this video
for a preview of the talks thanks for
watching
[Music]
you